[Musique]
des ébauches des croquis le point de
départ de la conception du costume qu'il
soit d'apparat ou traditionnels il est
au coeur de l'exposition résonances
d'elancourt on est vraiment sur cette
idée là de quelque chose que l'on porte
sur soi mais que l'on porte devant un
public 1 dans l'idée de costumes il ya
vraiment l'idée d'être en spectacle
même pour traverser la rue
éventuellement voilà ça dépend si vous
on envisage cette traversée de la rue
comme une performance mais pourquoi pas
des costumes résolument contemporain ces
artistes franciliens sont exposés
six femmes plasticienne et costumière
mais aussi des travaux d'élèves ceux de
l'école d'arts plastiques de la commune
j'ai souhaité les faire travailler eux
aussi sur cette notion de costumes
justement on a beaucoup travaillé déjà
sur la différence entre le costume labit
le vêtement et puis on a expérimenté
comme matière le papier on a essayé de
voir un petit peu tout ce qu'on pouvait
faire avec du papier ils ont découvert
des choses incroyables de la peinture à
la sculpture résonance emmène sur les
podiums de défilés de mode dans le
rapport vêtements peau et place le
costume dans la lumière
[Musique]